let's hear it right now for Mariah Carey
Mariah Carey took the stage for Dick
Clark's New Year's rockin Eve and things
started off strong
[Music]
but right after that the performance of
her hint emotions did not go as planned
[Applause]
[Music]
gary told the audience she could not
hear she attempted to sing a few times
and at one point handed the vocals over
since the performance there's been
controversy over what exactly went down
the singer told the crowd quote we
didn't have a soundcheck and at one
point said quote get these monitors on
please but through it all she kept her
own emotions pretty in check telling the
crowd Happy New Year and remaining the
diva that is Mariah that was following
the show Carey's team told ET quote
technical difficulties there
unfortunately was nothing she could do
to continue with the performance given
the circumstances and back and forth
began Dick Clark Productions gave et a
statements that said in part quote an
initial investigation has indicated that
DCP had no involvement in the challenges
associated with miscarries New Year's
Eve performance the company added they
have the utmost respect for the singer
but Mariah's team is standing firm her
rep told et Sunday night that given the
technical issues the singer was
experiencing the show should have cut to
commercial
[Music]
Oh